c'est parti pour une électrode vous
n'avez pas votre langue atelier vous
votez chez vous avez aimé ou pas quand
on a un projet comme ça qu'ils étaient
présents de longues semaines avoir sept
profils finale avec de [ __ ] tout seul
qui sans les papiers c'est d'une
tristesse absolue le principe même de
koh lanta c'est de célébrer de fêter la
fin d'une saison de voir les candidats
de leur parle de poser des questions de
voir la gagnant qui prend son chèque
c'est la fête là c'était d'une c'est la
sinistrose mais quelle horreur dont
clément saad a pris pour la deuxième
fois 100 millions 100 mille euros mais
attend on l'a pas vue et elle n'est pas
présente mais on peut pas faire ça sur
un penalty fort que koh lanta est
d'ailleurs la preuve on pensait
d'ailleurs tout ça avait bien marché à
cause du buzz ça n'a fait que 5 millions
3 cm grosso modo le même score que l'an
dernier était le plus mauvais
franchement c'est un coup à abîmer
vraiment le format parce que les gens
pensent que des gens qui ont vu qu'ils
ont suivi l'émission ils sont frustrés
n'y a pas de fête et pas de finale n'y a
pas de cotillons n'y a rien voilà enfin
si je bats lama le seul truc tu as
retenu l'émission c'est quand donniez
des pieds les pneus les papilles excuse
moi ça dure est quand même à 12h30 et
sera battu qu'est-ce que tu regardes me
pour la finale mais non mais non la
finesse a duré pendant deux heures
c'était deux bons mois pas plus mais je
reconnais c'est pas du niveau de cash à
élan donné l'accord à part ça quand même
je trouvais que c'était highbeam dans sa
gueule
alors quand même moi je trouve que c'est
la seule grande émission quand même pied
familiale un blockbuster familial
elle n'a pas d'autre et sert à ça reste
un vrai spectacle voilà c'est pas une
émission de plateau à la seine saint
denis ces voix-là aux îles fidji faisait
beau il ya du sueur des sentiments ont
fermé juste ses missions qui prennent
soin interactif cherchent chacun a ses
favoris
moi je regardais danse avec les stars je
sois untel ou untel guillaume en fout là
chacun son favori un peu comme dans miss
france c'est un vrai animateur qu'un
discute à une belle gagnante clémence
tous étaient tous qu'on ait tout ce
qu'on aime à la télévision et des vraies
valeurs j'ai adoré alors est-ce que vous
avez aimé ou pas aimer vos autour de la
table jean vieux t'as pas aimé
je voulais être convaincu par
jean-michel puis malheureusement je l'aï
écouté non mais je suis je suis d'accord
des parchemins quand même cessé de près
le trait des desmans même si honnêtement
la petite soirée qu'ils ont improvisé au
rex était plutôt sympathique ça c'est
bien après mais j'ai jamais été un fan
de koh lanta est de voir des mecs trois
ans sur des poteaux
même si s'est réduit au montage je suis
désolé non on parlera pas la blague de
butt
votre reprise est ce que c'est
insupportable